we begin in the u.s city of nashville in
the state of tennessee where a massive
explosion has rocked the downtown core
early on christmas morning
police there are calling it an
intentional act
they say the blast was linked to a
vehicle three people have been injured
but no fatalities have been reported
several rows of buildings have been
damaged
chabritanzi is live for us in washington
dc so she have any indication of
who did this
very little information right now we do
now have a more interesting
timeline to reports though it seems that
around 1200
gmt just before 1200 gmt police were
called
about a suspicious rv that is a
recreational vehicle
what we call a motorhome or a camper van
in the rest of the world
there was a suspicious vehicle parked on
a street
which didn't have any number plates
apparently so the police were called a
police officer
went to the scene and decided that this
was a suspicious vehicle and
alerted the the bomb squad effectively
the local bomb squad to come and take a
look at it while
further reinforcements were on their way
there was this explosion the explosion
is linked to
the vehicle there hasn't been any
explicit suggestion that it was the
vehicle but certainly that's certainly
what
what people are drawing from from the
circumstantial evidence
an enormous explosion we're seeing from
social media that people miles away felt
the explosion we're seeing the damage
in all the video that's been being
released around
20 buildings at least have been have
been damaged we should correct some news
some recording that we had earlier
though that this was outside the att
skyscraper that's actually around the
corner from here but but it was in the
vicinity of an atant
building that's used which has lots of
switching equipment for local
telecommunications
infrastructure also around lots of
restaurants it's a recently gentrified
area
on the riverfront in nashville we
understand the fbi
has now taken control of the
investigation and we are expecting
another update
shortly from local authorities perhaps
the mayor or the fbi
and she had any indication this at this
point in time from officials about
you know what the target might have been
absolutely not and we have no
information about
what it was i mean it's an rv that there
might have been speculation initially
that
you know these rvs carry gas canises off
trawl they carry they have kitchens on
board perhaps
but we have no information i mean it's
pure speculation right now all we can
say is
have is a circumstantial evidence that
occurred early on christmas morning and
in fact authorities are saying
it's very lucky that this happened at a
time when there weren't that many people
around just the people who were living
in the adjacent buildings the various
loft-style apartments that are around
only three people were injured not
critically but they have been taken to
hospital
all right thanks so much you have
britancy there